all right it looks like we are now live
so welcome back everybody who is going
to be here who is going to be watching
this uh this is part of a series called
understanding anger 2.0 and I'll tell
you a little bit about that since we're
trying to get the the whole series back
on track so this is something that I
started earlier this year of
2023 and it it stemmed from my teaching
classes at Marquette University
specifically focused on anger it's part
of a Core Curriculum where we got to
choose a particular problem and since I
do so much work on anger in literature
and philosophy and other uh sources and
since I do a lot of work with my clients
on Anger Management I thought well I'll
share this with my students and then
people start started saying hey you know
you did this series years and years ago
back in 2015 called understanding anger
maybe you should start doing that again
so I thought about it and I was like
yeah that's actually a great
idea um and I can do it in an open-ended
way it doesn't have to finish after just
a year or 12 sessions we can keep going
on and on and go into as much depth or
detail as we like so earlier this year
we got off to a start we've been looking
at anger in a couple philosophers
particularly Plato and Aristotle but we
also looked at anger in uh literature
and that's what we're going to be doing
today so we've looked at um Homer's
Iliad and hess's works and now we're
going to be looking at Greek tragedy
starting with one of the very first
important tragedians eelus who wrote
this very interesting Trilogy called the
orista so I'll tell you about that in
just a bit I do want to sort of
highlight that next year we're going to
be looking at more tragedy we're going
to be starting off the Year by looking
at ureides Meda and Sophocles Ajax two
plays where anger plays a massively
important role which are also mentioned
by the philosophical literature here and
there and then we'll get into some more
philosophical stuff with the epicurian
tradition and the stoics and and and
we'll be sort of moving around and it
won't all be just Greek you know we're
going to start getting into some Latin
sources as well with for example
lucretius and senica and Cicero but you
know for the most part it's going to be
Greeks for a while so I hope you can
join me for those uh sets as well and if
you want to see the older uh class
sessions you can find them quite easily
in the you know various playlists that I
have so enough about that um what are we
doing this session we are looking at as
I mentioned depictions of anger and its
workings in a number of different
contexts and we can identify these as
familial because this is about a family
a particularly messed up family as so
many of the ones in Greek tragedies and
legends are but also uh political and
divine or religious contexts and uh
they're centered in these Trilogy of
tragedies by achelis the orista so the
first play is called Agamemnon I
actually read it as an undergraduate in
a world literature class and I'm so
happy that I did because it turned me on
to a play right who I'd heard about but
never read and it was such a cool play
for reasons we'll talk about um then
there's the libation bearers and then
there's a third play the humanties the
peaceful ones who are actually the
furies and these are really uh quite
interesting from a number of different
perspectives so it's not just all about
anger and revenge and their workings
there's a bunch of different things
going on in these plays now we're not
going to get
theoretical um Dimensions or
interpretations of anger as we did in
previous sessions looking at for example
what Aristotle has to say about anger
what Plato has to say about anger um
instead what we get are depictions of
anger and perhaps um warnings references
to how dangerous anger and its Dynamics
can can be and these are very very
compelling some some of the characters
actually turn out to be
personifications of among other things
anger for example the furies as we're
going to look at now we might be able to
draw some lessons from these so it's not
as if there aren't any lessons that
could be called out of this but they're
not right there on the surface so we do
have to uh do a bit of work and maybe
we'll do that in the discussion that we
have after we walk our way through these
plays and I do want to begin with
something not from eelis but from
Aristotle who is one of the very first
people in the west to think very deeply
about the nature of tragedy and
Aristotle if you've ever read the
Poetics you know that he
identifies six main um key he let's call
them Dimensions or elements uh or even
Parts he says of tragedy and three of
them he says are most important um and
then three are they're not unimportant
but they're less important and there's
good news about this so what are the
three most important ones he says the
most important thing is plot or story
MOS the the story that is being
related and set out then second most
important is character or Athos uh the
kind of person that we we have here and
that's something that comes up for
discussion in here is this person guilty
is this person innocent is this person a
good person are they a bad person you
know a lot of this has to do with how
they behave but it also has to do with
the third dimension which is um what we
typically translate as thought
dioa and this means the motivations and
the thought processes of the characters
as they're revealed to us in their
discourse and in discourse that others
are saying about them as well and how
they respond to that so those those we
can appreciate without ever putting the
play up on stage now of course you know
a play isn't quite the same thing as
just the written document that we have
it's meant to be actually seen and to a
certain extent as an audience
participate in it uh but you know we got
to go with what we've got um we don't
get an awful lot of opportunities to see
these acted out but I I do want to
mention there are three other important
elements um what we can call song or
lyric poetry Melos uh diction the way in
which things are said uh which is Lexus
and then spectacle which is opsis you
know putting the actual stage together
uh the costumes the movements those
sorts of things so we don't get those
other three um but we get enough of the
three most important ones that we can
say we we actually grasp the essence of
the play um now before we jump in let me
quickly respond to just a few comments
so Mark is here good to see you um
thanks I'm I'm glad that you enjoy the
understanding anger series I'm certainly
having a lot of fun with it myself and
it's a great opportunity for me to go
back to texts that otherwise I might not
spend enough time on uh Samira says
today started this planning to follow
the whole series okay yeah so that's
good um we will be doing these monthly
we we haven't been doing them the last
few months because I've been pretty busy
with classes and with some some
illnesses but uh in the coming year
I'm hoping we can get 12 more sessions
in which will bring it to 20 right and
I'll I'll announce what we've got coming
up later on in the the year all right so
I mentioned a familial setting and I
think that having a little bit of
backstory can be quite helpful um you
get a good portion of it narrated to you
explain to you through the characters in
these plays part particularly in the
Agamemnon you get you get a good section
of backstory there but let's let's talk
about this so we have this character
several Generations back named Tantalus
and Tantalus is just a prime jerk he is
a king he is um somebody who wants to
test the gods so he actually invites
them over for a banquet and he kills his
own own son palop and he cuts them up
into pieces puts them in the stew and
the only God who doesn't see right away
that this is human flesh and we don't
want to have you know anything like this
going on is Deiter who is mourning her
lost daughter panie and she accidentally
eats his shoulder the rest of the gods
are like buddy this is not okay and they
uh do a couple things one is uh Tantalus
is sent down to hell to Hades and he's
punished there eternally this is what we
get the word tantalize from and uh his
son pelops is brought back to life but
they have to give him a golden
shoulder um and um he winds up having
two children Atrius and the
Estes now these two sons Atrius and
thees they don't really get along that
well and um they there's a bunch of
other stories surrounding them I'm just
going to stick to the the plot that's
most important for this so the Estes has
sex with atreus's wife
aope and Atrius retaliates in a horrific
way which sense a reproduction or a
recollection
of that um his ancestor had done so he
takes uh um the est's sons and butchers
them and puts them into a stew while
cutting off
their and you know serves it to his
brother his brother eats it and then he
says oh by the way that's your kids in
there do do you like the taste of that
and he brings out the heads and hands
and um the Estes then um winds up having
sex with actually raping his own
daughter ppia why because there's a
prophecy that whatever son he has from
that will kill um the eses and uh his
his son is agist who is one of the
important characters in this story
meanwhile um Atrius is going to have two
sons uh Agamemnon and manalus and um
they get involved in the Trojan War I
think many of you know this story uh
Agamemnon becomes the Great War leader
menaus who's not quite as great of a
warrior as
Agamemnon um is uh he's the one who
actually wins the most beautiful woman
in all of wherever Greece you know the
Mediterranean Helen who winds up being
seduced by Alexander or Paris of Troy
who uh then brings her to Troy and then
then you know the Greeks sail a thousand
ships I think all of us are pretty
familiar with this story right so we've
got these in the background who does by
the way kill uh Atrius uh and then we've
got these two brothers going off to Troy
and before they can actually sail
Agamemnon who has married C manestra and
has had uh three children with
her is told that if the if there isn't a
sacrifice the fleet can't sail and so
now he's the war leader is responsible
for all of this stuff and they you know
he sacrifices who he's told to sacrifice
he ifag Genia who doesn't want to be
sacrificed you know and this enrages CL
minestra as we're going to find out so
the first play is going to begin with
Agamemnon returning home from Troy with
uh a war captive Cassandra who's a
prophetess who nobody believes
CTO manestra by this time has has either
been seduced by or chosen to take aisus
as a lover and she's planning revenge
against Agamemnon meanwhile areses
Agamemnon and CTO minestra son is
elsewhere and he's going to return home
later on um and we'll talk about that in
just a bit and he'll meet up with his
his sister Electra at that point so
that's that's the familial backstory and
setting and you see there's already a
lot of outrage and crime and um
dishonoring and and anger going on
within all of this now there's several
key themes to these plays one of these
is the question of who's actually in the
right where does Justice lie you know
one way of understanding tragedy that n
pointed out to
us is that
it involves
competing understandings of what is
right and wrong of of normativity that
can't all be brought into harmony with
each other and so we have to make
difficult decisions that are never
really great decisions uh for us right
and these have massive impact on other
people as well as ourselves they often
involve the gods and stuff like that so
this question where does Justice
actually lie near the end of Agamemnon
the
chorus is going to speak of being at a
loss as being
deprived of of intellect or practical
wisdom not having ready thought at um
you know as a resource to turn to they
they're they're perplexed they don't
know who is actually doing the right
thing and who who's who's done you know
completely the wrong thing because each
of these characters will be able to give
a pretext there's nobody who says I love
evil for its own sake they're all like
well I'm gonna do this because this this
thing over here was wrong and I'm going
to impose some justice and then the
justice that they impose winds up also
being an injustice right and they do so
out of anger out of a desire for revenge
or retaliation and so this is the other
key theme this cycle that goes on from
generation to generation of offense of
violence of retaliation it affects
entire cities it spills over inter
relations between the Divine beings
themselves so what these screwed up
human beings with their their you know
messed up family history end up doing
has massive effects reverberating
throughout the cosmos or at least a
certain part of it that's why it could
become the subject of of
tragedy so we'll we'll talk about the
plot and structure of the the three
plays and then we we'll talk about um
the furies and the role that they play
and then maybe we'll pause for a bit of
you know Q&A and
discussion and uh then we'll we'll go
into each play in turn so giving you a
thumbnail sketch right we've already
mentioned the beginning of the agnan
he's coming home they've actually lit
these beacons top you know the fleet is
coming back home from Troy after 10
years and what's what's going on
here um CID minestra agamemnon's wife
has been in charge for quite a long time
and she is setting things up in such a
way to entangle Agamemnon figuratively
and literally within a net that he won't
be able to get out of and then to
sacrifice him as he sacrificed their her
daughter ifag Genia which she is still
angry about and I guess this wants to
kill him too right because there's this
bad blood between him and his cousins
going back to to to their fathers uh and
so this has been going on for uh
multiple generations and they will in
fact murder Agamemnon and they will also
murder Cassandra who interestingly can
see what's going to happen the chorus
which is always an important thing in
Greek tragedy is the old men of Argos
the you know Council of
Elders and they uh attempt to call out
clyto minestra and auses and say that
you know they're going to take revenge
they're gonna they're gonna impose
Justice on them and it turns out that
they're not powerful enough to do that
and C of manester and I guess this are
like yeah go ahead buddies we'll take
care of you you want us to kill you off
and it ends with saying well arrestes is
Gonna Come and he'll he'll put the these
matters right right so now we got a
hostile situation created between the
son of Agamemnon and CTO minestra and
CTO minestra and and agist these so in
the libation bearers areses is the main
character really he comes back to
Revenge his father's murder because
Apollo has told him that he has to do
that and we're gonna look at you know
the ins and outs of that in just a
little bit so he said kind of dam if you
damn if you don't situation he's been
told by
Apollo's blood has to be Avenged uh
happens it's your mom and this guy gist
these who you're gonna have to take care
of in in this and so he comes back
and he meets up with uh the chorus and
uh Electra and the chorus is the female
Servants of CTO minestra the libation
Bears they're they're at the tomb of
Agamemnon who is not resting
peacefully and areses an Electra meet
they recognize each other and they make
plans to enter the house and kill aist
this and CTO manestra and that's what
they do they they kill aist these they
trick him to get entrance and then C
manestra comes out and she's like hey
you can't kill me son that's matricide
and you know I raised you and I also had
a good reason to kill your father and
and then he killed her and it finishes
with him beginning to see the
furies now in the third one the
humanities we get to meet the furies and
the Furies in this case are the chorus
so this is a very interesting
Innovation they are one of instead of St
sitting back and saying ah this is
what's going on you know here's some
backstory and all that they are some of
the protagonists you could say in this
clash
between different ideas of right and
wrong and so the Furies are pursuing
areses and he he seeks Sanctuary first
from Apollo and Apollo is able to give
him some and then he sends him off when
the furies fall asleep to Athens and to
become a supplant of
Athena now the furies are the old order
the gods of you know the Earth of old
time of Vengeance and they are arguing
that Apollo is doing the wrong thing and
that uh Athena shouldn't be protecting
areses and if she does there's going to
be dire consequences for her City and
Athena gets them to agree that she will
hear their case and render a verdict and
she says well this is too big we need a
jury we need we need to actually do a
vote about this and you know this is
about Athenian democracy to some degree
as well as about religious matters and
about revenge and and when they do hear
the casee Athena is going to cast the
deciding vote and then the furies are
mad because she has allowed their victim
to evade justice so they're going to
destroy the land and she MiFi the fury
she finds a way to
overcome their anger and so if there's
you know we talked about are there
lessons here to be drawn well perhaps
part of it besides you know know how how
um beastial and horrifying anger can can
be maybe it's also about the need for
patience for restoring relationships in
some respect and showing people that
think that they have been Dishonored
slighted disrespected that that's not
actually the case by making a place for
them as Athena will do with the furies
in Athens so let's look at the furies uh
because they play an important role uh
in in a lot of things they're already
mentioned in the
Agamemnon in a number of different ways
so we don't actually see the furies as
characters instead it people who wind up
being you could
say agents of the furies so early on in
the Agamemnon it's mentioned that Zeus
or pan or Apollo will send a fury to
avenge wrongdoing in this case it's
sending atreus's Sons Agamemnon and
manalus against Paris Paris is the one
who seduced another person's wife who
stole her away and so he's gonna have to
pay and his city is going to have to pay
um much later in the play we find out
that and here's here's sort of a line
from it Danger is a people's voice
charged with wrath it acts as a curse of
publicly ratified Doom in anxious fear I
wait to hear something shrouded still in
Gloom the gods are not blind to men with
blood on their hands in the end the
black spirits of Vengeance bring to
obscurity that one who has prospered in
unrighteousness and wear down his
fortunes right so you know there's a lot
of uh words in there you know curses the
heaviness
danger and it's it's really quite
interesting here so kotos is one of the
words that's being used for anger or
wrath here and then we also have um
democat being mentioned here so it's not
just uh you know a people or something
like that it's
um it's anthens or other places where
there's some sort of
participatory um engagement it's not
just a king running everything and we
see that Menace is used there uh a word
that starts off The Iliad and so we've
got these these two different uh terms
that are being used for anger or for
wrath in this and and I should mention
that the language that eelus is using is
quite similar to that as we find in
hessed and Homer and not all that
similar to what we see in in Aristotle
and Plato later on where instead of
talking about you know um hos or Menace
or kotos we're going to see other more
uh contemporary terms Like Ur or thumos
being used now we will see those a
little bit in these plays
so later on uh we find that CID manestra
is swearing by the avenging Fury ironin
right
um avenging her daughter ifag Genia she
is going to be a fury so Agamemnon has
been an agent of the fury uh CTO
manestra is going to be an agent of the
fury as well and then even
aises will end up saying I I see this
man lying here in a net spun by the
avenging
Spirits so by the um the translation
here
of right the the furies and making full
payment for the Deeds contrived in craft
by his father's hand against this views
himself as an Avenger of what his father
had to put up with having his his sons
butchered and and served to him you know
essentially uh you know avenging his
brothers and his father so there's a lot
of
there and if you have any questions or
comments we'll address those and then
we'll actually look at uh these three
plays and some of the passages from them
that are
particularly important and what's going
on on in them as far as anger goes so
any uh ideas that you want to bring up
talk about uh ask questions
about um I'm uh you know we've got
plenty of time allotted for this sort of
thing uh what is on your
minds while people are writing anything
down that they want to write down I'll
mention that um you know going back to
Aristotle it's interesting because if
you've read or read about his theory of
tragedy he talks about the
audience um undergoing what we often
translate is
purification of certain
emotions those emotions being fear and
pity fobos and alos in
Greek and he doesn't say that it's it's
only those
emotions and we could think of uh anger
itself as potentially being one of the
emotions that is invoked but also we
wind up um purifying ourselves of by
participating in the play by investing
ourselves by identifying to a certain
extent um
and allowing ourselves to feel things
and then perhaps seeing the futility of
the anger so Mark says cannibalism is a
good metaphor for anger's
impact yeah cannibalism or being uh a
predator right um the furies themselves
when we see them
personified are scary scary creatures
and they're scary not just in their
described appearance but in how they how
they talk how they presents M El they
don't just make threats they um they use
doglike language you know like scary
dogs um they're almost like a peack you
could say pursuing their their
Quarry and why do they do it because
they're in their view they're entirely
in the right right and you think about
the way that people behave now no longer
just you know divine creature
but us when we get angry we're prone to
do all sorts of bad things precisely
because in that situation even though we
can recognize them as bad things bad
actions bad sayings we say well it's
Justified as a response as retaliation
as setting things right as equalizing
things you know they hurt me or they
hurt people who matter to me I hurt them
and we could say well hurting people you
know and revenge are not a good thing
well they're good in this case and we
have a tendency even if we're right
about that sometimes you know to go way
way too far and and the Furies and some
of these characters are great
representations of that interestingly
one of the the people who doesn't seem
to exist exemplify the emotion of anger
but does act in accordance with what
anger uh
desires is uh areses himself right he uh
he he's acting because he's required to
avenge his father his father is angry
right angry for being killed and
betrayed by his wife um and you know
these Restless Spirits are are part of
the picture as well the Restless Dead we
could say any other questions comments
before we go on and look at the uh plays
[Music]
themselves all right doesn't look like
we have any so maybe we'll do a little
bit more Q&A in just a bit so the
Agamemnon the first play in the
the chorus Begins by invoking this theme
of blood and bloodshed both applied to
CTO minestra but coming from this
Prophet cus who has uh you
know told Agamemnon that you're gonna
have to sacrifice your daughter um the
gods are expecting this in order for you
to be able to sail to Troy and so
Agamemnon chooses to do this terrible
thing to to let the blood of his own kin
um and to deprive um his wife of one of
their children and so Phobos fear fear
is brought up there uh treachery doia is
brought up as well and we see again this
ter Manus wrath anger the very word that
begins the um o not the Odyssey the
Iliad and you know speak of the wrath of
Achilles that's Manus right and so one
translation for there abides wrath
terrible not to be suppressed a
treacherous guardian of the home wrath
that never forgets and exacts Vengeance
for a
child um we also see this character
Cassandra and she is a propus who was
beloved by the god
Apollo and uh um he gave her the power
to prophesy which we typically think of
as like oriented primarily towards the
future but we see that the capacity to
prophesy in this and also in other Greek
stories means a capacity to see what is
actually going on when she is brought as
a war captive into the house of
Agamemnon and CTO minestra she's looking
around and she's like oh my God look at
all this horror surrounding me she not
only sees that she's going to die that
agamemnon's going to die that a
sacrifice is going to take place she
sees that this house is a house full of
old unreconciled blood and so she sees
it as a a horror
scene now why um doesn't
she appeal to anybody well because she
was given the capacity to prophesy by
Apollo Apollo wanted to have sex with
her she promised to have sex with him
and then broke her promise so Apollo
became angry uh the word there kotos you
know again another common Greek anger
word and he cursed her meaning that she
would not be listened to anymore so she
gets she knows what's going on she just
can't get anyone else to believe her and
so it's interesting we see that anger
has led to this result um CID minestra
is going to um uh you know talk about um
the furies again shall say this is
towards the end of the play now you have
corrected the Judgment of your lips in
that you name the thric gorged fiend of
this race for by him the Lust For
lapping blood is fostered in the mou so
wound is healed fresh blood is spilled
and we see blood being talked about over
and over again throughout this plan you
know um and what we see here is the
furies are being invoked daona right is
is the the term that's being used for
them um these avenging creatures right
so the Agamemnon is filled with the
effects of anger and the cycle of
Revenge of dis dishonor extreme dishonor
and people who just don't recognize that
they may have done the right thing in
one respect but they did a wrong thing
from the vantage point of other people
who have been hurt who have been damaged
who are now themselves angry and seeking
Revenge who you know allow their anger
to curdle into hatred and contempt for
each other so that's that's what's going
on in this play the Agamemnon and they
do kill him right and then the chorus
threatens punishment and C manestra and
G this are like screw you you know try
your best we'll kill you you know we
were in the right so then we fast
forward
years and we get the libation Bears and
the chorus now is coming with offerings
to the dead who's the dead here
Agamemnon who G
is haunting the place and we get this
really interesting
line uh of anger uh coming from sleep
exu koton right anger koton uh hnos is
sleep and we we learn as well
indignation lives among the dead and
Vengeance against those who kill so we
have a
unrestful spirit
who can't move on to wherever he's
supposed to right and here we see the
word thumos coming up peros as a adverb
um
to right against those who have who have
uh uh been killed and against those who
who kill right and we we discover that
Electra the daughter of c minestra and
and Agamemnon hates aises and she's
hoping for the desire she's hoping for
the return of her banished brother
areses she loves her
father She Wants Revenge and we see her
talking about bitter Gul in her heart
and the word for Gul there is a
holes this is another word for anger uh
it does mean Gul uh it also means the
liver which was understood as the seat
of the emotions in particular that of
anger and so we see also the word cardia
right her her heart her heart has been
blackened by by Gall right and then we
get arrestes and arestes is showing up
here with his his friend and he meets up
with Electra at the tomb and he reveals
to her that he has been told by Apollo
that he must uh avenge his father now
does Apollo say kill your mother no he
says you have to avenge your father your
father's blood is is calling out if you
don't you're going to pay areses you're
not doing your duty as a son and what
will happen then the furies will come
after him uh the irones right uh driven
by the guilt of blood uh the guilt of of
of familial blood right so he's being
compelled to take action which will
result in shedding more
blood um in order to to rectify in order
to um impose retribution for the action
taken against his his
father the chorus notes that the dead
themselves will have anger or angers and
here we do see the word oras right um so
that's one of the few uses of this uh
term that Plato and Aristotle use a lot
the dead will have anger if they're not
justly Avenged and so we we read it is
the Eternal rule that drops of blood
spilled on the ground demand more blood
murder cries out on the fury which from
those killed before brings one ruin in
the wake of another so again the furies
will uh pursue areses if he doesn't do
the right thing he'll be an avenging
Fury if he does do what Apollo is
telling him to do and areses makes his
way into the house uh formerly of his
father now of his
stepfather uh aises who's also his
father's cousin um and he's got no
problem killing Aus right he tricks him
and butchers him um no big deal there we
you know there's actually like a scream
off stage and Aus this is killed but
what about his mother she makes
appeals she has a certain kind of
justification on her side she tells him
you know I suckled you I gave birth to
you you cannot kill me you cannot do
anything against me because that would
be wrong on your part you would be
showing incredible ingratitude and
Injustice in doing so and he's he's not
really listening to that and then she
says well your father did wrong I killed
him because he killed our daughter he
killed your sister and he didn't have
good reason to do that now of course the
ships couldn't have sailed to Troy but
tough for him right um so she's making a
a rational case to him and um you know
he's conflicted about this uh she tells
him that uh his his Vengeance would be
wrong to do right and he winds up being
unresolved for a bit about this we see
that uh he says at my heart fear wishes
to sing and dance a tune of Wrath and
this is after he takes action and kills
her prosta cardia Phobos Adan
toos
ho Koto once again we see kotos this
anger word being used and we see the
heart being invoked as well the heart is
inhabited by anger but also by dread or
fear two very important emotions here
you can be angry you can be following
that you can be riled up and yet fearful
of your consequences at the same time
even when you think you're doing the
right thing in some respects you could
have some inkling in the back of your
mind whoa I'm really going far here I'm
killing my
mother surely this can't be the right
thing to do but it is the right thing to
do
right after he kills her he begins to
see the furies and now the furies are no
longer this sort of like threat hanging
over the blood you know blood Letter
it's no longer something that we by
doing Justice to those that have done
Injustice can be an agent of they are
beings that are revealing themselves but
to him not to the other people they're
all like hey man what's what's going on
with you and he's
like I see the furies over there and
they are
horrific and I don't know what I'm going
to do that's the end of the libation
Bears so we've had a certain kind of
resolution then we get uh the humanities
and now um we have the furies as
personifications of anger wrath
indignation
revenge and they're they're said to be
not women but rather Gorgons right and
uh even that isn't enough of a a
comparison gorgens I call them yet I
cannot compare them to forign forms of
Gorgons either once before I saw some
creatures in a painting carrying off the
Feast of Phineas but these are wingless
in appearance black altogether
disgusting they snore with repulsive
breaths they drip from their eyes
hateful drops right they
are very very terrifying creatures and
they are Divine they are something that
has existed uh not from the very
beginning of the world but close to its
Beginnings longer than the newer Gods
who we going to see so arestes makes it
to the shrine of Apollo and the Furies
are there and they're being described by
you know the the uh uh people there and
also by Apollo himself and um they fall
asleep and Apollo sends areses to Athens
he's like like you better get while the
getting's good buddy so go to Athens go
to Athena she will help you out here and
what do we find out is going on before
we had the ghost of
Agamemnon now we have the ghost or the
the figure the adalone the image of CID
manestra she comes on the scene and she
wakes the furies and it takes a little
while for them to wake up and they're
making dog kind of noises while this is
happening right kind of murmuring and
she tells them that she has been
Dishonored uh the word there
isas may right um I have been Dishonored
by you you're supposed to be avenging me
you're screwing up you're not doing your
job right and she Rouses them with these
complaints they make doglike sounds
right and
then they they have this speech which
rightly been you know called out by some
some
commentators um they they're saying get
him get him get him get him right
they're driven by this this passion for
revenge in Greek it's four times being
said laba laba laba laba and then fru
You know it's and you could imagine them
on stage and people being kind of
horrified by by this the furies
themselves are angry and they're angry
sort of in a general way they're really
mad at Apollo they've lost their prey
due to this young upstart Apollo Justice
isn't being done properly by these
younger gods and they accuse Apollo of
being responsible for ares's sin and
then we get this interesting exchange he
accuses them of being unjust themselves
in focusing too much on blood and the
satisfaction of you know uh revenge for
those who let their their uh kinsmen's
blood and not focusing enough on
marriage which he says is more important
than an oath right and
interestingly
um he points out an inconsistency he
says listen if you're going to go after
arrestes for this sort of thing then you
should also show wrath to cly of
minestra but you don't show wrath to Cly
manestra so you're inconsistent you
Furies you're actually unjust yourself
right and he says that if I forsake my
supplant there is also going to be anger
for me Anger from from who we don't
really know he just says there's going
to be Manus and again in this this line
we have kotos we have Manus we have
these These Old anger words that we've
seen already from the time of
Homer so it goes on and we see that the
furies get to talk quite a bit they say
that a person whose hands are clean will
not cause their anger and again we see
the word Manus right and that they are
the enforcers of Law and Justice and
fate now they come to Athens and Athena
is like whoa what are these things holy
crap who are you right and they're like
well we're the furies we're here to take
this guy arrest
uh you better turn him over to us
because um if you don't there's going to
be consequences so they explain what
they are they explain their their case
to Athena and then she says that there
was a power whose anger areses feared
and that's Apollo right so this is why
he did what he did and she accuses the
furies of actually being more about the
appearance of Justice than than doing
Justice right that's what their desire
is and um you know Athena notes the
danger that if the furies lose their
case the anger will fall on on Athens
her land and the Furies also say that if
their anger if their kotos doesn't fall
on the wrongdoers there's going to be
social consequences political
consequences the furies are there to
impose a certain sort of Justice a
certain sort of Revenge
right and it's specifically about those
who shed their kinsmen's blood they say
that if if their anger doesn't fall on
wrongdoers Justice is going to be
subverted and people will call on them
in vain and then fear will go away and
along with it justice so this is a a
significant problem they're making a
rational argument there for why this
cycle of of you know blood leing uh
retaliation Revenge punishment has to go
on uh Apollo is going to make a case
himself and a bit of a side note on this
he's gonna make an argument that is has
been looked at by by other people as
being something important in Ancient
Greek culture it's a little bit
debatable sometimes people make too much
of this but he says um that the father's
death is is a bigger problem than the
mother's death essentially the father
has a greater weight than the mother he
claims that Zeus himself has ordained
this so he's bringing in you know his
dad um he's he's appealing to the king
of the Gods and he also says that the
father is more the parent of the child
than the mother is which is an
interesting idea there so that's why
Apollo could say Agamemnon is appealing
to me you got to do something about it
arties I it's sad that you got to kill
your mom but you know father outweighs
the mother and the Furies once again
reiterate that if Apollo wins they are
going to vent their anger and the word
there is thumos thi right they're going
to exhibit their thumos against the city
po the
polus and what ends up happening the
jury is split 6 to6
right uh six people condemning areses
six people holding him innocent Athena
cast the final vote on the favor of
areses taking up Apollo's case and um
the furi now are Furious right and so
they start saying uh the old is being
trampled by the new we've been
Dishonored and they several times say
we're going to unleash poison and
disease and it's repeated several times
it's sort of like how angry people will
keep saying the same thing over and over
again and what ends up happening Athena
begins a strategy that takes several
different steps of appeasing the furies
of saying that they aren't Dishonored
asking them to stop their their anger so
she
says
Kon Scapes so we've got thumos right
which coming from thumos and it's a verb
in that case don't don't remain angry
don't remain riled up and then allow
your you know heavy wrath to dissipate
stop this this anger and now there's two
parts of this she's not just being a
dummy and saying calm down that's not a
big deal right that never helps with
angry people as we I think know from
from
experience um but she is saying oh you
know you're not being Dishonored I'm not
actually favoring Apollo I'm favoring
Justice and we are gonna find a place
for you we're we've got uh something set
aside for you here in Athens and then
the furies repeat their threats and
complaints and she again says that they
should relent in their anger made Hooper
thumos right don't uh don't allow your
anger to run away with you don't allow
to to get get higher and finally It Ends
by Athena saying here's what I'm going
to do how would you like to be and it's
kind of a funny way to say it how would
you like to be part of a community that
is on the rise Athens is a city that is
you know new but it's gonna be really
big it's gonna be a a big deal how' you
like to get on the ground floor you can
be part
of the whole system of justice you don't
have to be Freelancers doing things on
your own you will have a place here in
the city and the Furies are
like okay that that doesn't sound bad uh
I think that could be quite good I'm
actually gonna read you uh just just a a
line from this um so actually sever
several lines so they say let Civil War
and satiate of ill never in Athens rage
let burning wrath that murder must
assuage never take arms to spill in this
my Heritage the blood of man till dust
is drunk its fill let all together find
joy in each other and each both love and
hate with the same mind as his blood
brother for this heals many hurts of
mankind so there's a
Reconciliation that is taking place
place here at the end now Clay minestra
is still dead you know agamemnon's still
dead agist is still dead all this curse
that lay behind them still had its
effect but it's been
overcome and arrestes can go on living
his life and we have a new sort of
situation this is often talked about in
terms of like the first law court and
all that but in terms of what we're
looking at this is in in some respect
about overcoming the cycle of offense
and anger and um you know Justice on one
side being Injustice on the other side
and taking Revenge which then doesn't
resolve things but leads to further need
for revenge and bringing in these Primal
dangerous entities that that the Greeks
called the furies they're now part of a
system of justice not a perfect system
by any means but something something
something that will allow uh
possibilities all right so let's let's
uh go on to some of the questions donkey
has a bunch of things
here um I'm intrigued by your insights
into the Dynamics of anger as you delve
into the complexities of the emotion I'm
curious to hear your thoughts on Johnny
rotten's famous quote anger is an energy
um what do you think it means to harness
this energy for constructive and
positive change as Johnny Rotten
exemplified in his song Rise well I
think that too many people say that that
line anger is an energy sure it's an
energy it's most often a destructive
energy right and it can be
helpful uh within certain contexts but
when Justified for its own sake it so
easily gets out of whack and somebody
could be on the right track with anger
or over here and then you know a couple
years pass and they're still holding on
to it and they they you know their anger
sours curdles becomes hatred becomes
indignation I think that um you know
people like Aristotle Plato thought that
anger uh did work like an energy it did
Supply us with some of what we need but
as soon as it gets disentangled from
rationality we're in deep trouble so so
I think we have to be very very careful
with this idea I I don't I don't endorse
it in any sort of uh easy way right so
followup how can we harness the positive
aspects of thumos often associated with
anger particularly the righteous anger
that motivates individuals to defend
Justice and stand up for what is Right
while mitigating its destructive
Tendencies um
well that's that's where Plato and
Aristotle and other thinkers we're going
to look at epicurian um the stoics think
that anger doesn't have any good place
as does uh um cisero you know um but a
lot of the ancient thinkers think that
you can use anger effectively but you
got to be super super super careful
right you don't want to encourage the
vices which portray the anger as being
righteous you know for every one person
who actually has righteous anger that's
going to do something good there's
probably 10 who are calling their unjust
anger righteous and using that as an
excuse for doing whatever it is that
they're going to do and they're damaging
not just themselves in the process but
other people their relationships
oftentimes engaging in things that can't
be fixed you know um killing people
exiling people breaking
relationships um you know saying
horrible things that are going to damage
mad matters for people so it's
[Music]
um you know it's it's an emotion that
the ancient Greeks and Romans thought we
have to be very very careful with even
when they were justifying it and I think
that that's a dynamic that goes on to
this day um for every instance where we
can say aha that's righteous anger
there's probably multiple instances
where it's not and somebody is just
claiming that it is right
so um now the emergence of punk music we
could talk about now there is no like
single Motif that's behind the emergence
of any
music um and punk is an interesting
conglomeration of everything from like
youthful Rebellion to dissatisfaction
with um contemporary society and its
styles to DIY
musicianship to um you know
essentially being posers standing on
stage you know I mean we we see punk
bands that were put together by
promoters to be like the great punk
bands and stuff like that and and we can
say similar things about other kinds of
music as well you know heavy metal is
often associated with anger too um but
you know you don't always have the same
treatment of it right so you know think
about a band like Triumph and fight the
good fight right you can do that
actually Without Anger that's a
beautiful song you know um and and you
know Punk can Encompass a lot of things
not all punks are necessarily angry some
might just be crazy and aggressive you
know and then we get the whole Post Punk
thing where we have interesting bands
you know that I would say are motivated
to some degree by righteous anger but
not solely that way and are thoughtful
like New Model Army you know
um so yeah there's there's a lot that we
could say about music stuff um I don't
agree with with with donkey's assertion
that Metals Evolution starts with prag
rock again let's not be overs simplistic
about these sorts of things um metal has
a lot of different things that are going
on and blues is just as important
perhaps even more so than prag rock is
um so all right um LS says do you think
this is asus's attempt to explain
transition and reconcile the values we
see in Homer like the answer of using
the same word for the anger of Achilles
and then in his work no I I don't think
that's what's going on I think any more
than than hessed is by using the same
vocabulary just you know trying to work
off of Homer I think that these are
separate um
discourses that are largely being driven
by the reflection of the the people
themselves who are doing the composition
and reflecting their societies you know
um well eelis is story is set in the
same time as Homer's Iliad and
odyssey um he's writing in a in a very
different time period and he's writing
in a different place he's he's in Athens
participating in this um Festival one of
the first like really successful trag
Jans you know
um continuing on uh having characters
point out the furries Injustice of anger
in order to see the new Gods kind of
Justice the the new Gods versus the old
gods is not a homeric theme so much it's
more of a
hesticles Gods here and there and and
godets you know here and there but
um yeah I I I think that um eelus is is
engaging with these stories in a way
that is using the same vocabulary
because it's a common vocabulary other
other writers of the time are going to
be using that too my my statements about
the vocabulary the anger uh terminology
is more to point out that there's going
to be a break later
on not a complete break but more of an
emphasis when we read Plato when we read
Aristotle also when we look at um you
know later playwrights we're going to
see them using a a anger language that
uses
these um words like you know liver you
know holos much less and kotos and Manus
less although you will see them some
sometimes in Aristotle you're just going
to see thumos and Ur and things like
anane as a verb or
[Music]
umap as a verb you're GNA see those
things much more often and I I don't
think that that's like a deliberate
shift where people are like well the
anger vocabulary hasn't been doing you
know what we need it to we need a better
uh language for this I think it's just
you know suggestive of what's what's
going on in the language at the time and
I haven't done like a complete survey I
I you know it' be good to look at like
speech writers that are contemporary
with Plato and
Aristotle uh medical writers would be
very important to look at as well like
hypocrates and you know and maybe even
we need to look at historians and see
you know what what exact terms are being
used in Herodotus in um
tuties in and some of these these other
people as well so all right any other
questions comments
ideas if you haven't read these I mean I
highly recommend going and and checking
them out and you know like maybe take a
whole day to read through all three of
them you're going to see all this really
really cool stuff going on there it's
not all just about anger and revenge
there's also dread you know and uh these
these relations between the gods and St
stuff like that
um let's see
dami
teres let mean it's hard to read
here dami Trace uh lame nios the fur is
being incorporated into the community of
Athens at the end of the tragedy might
be symbolic of Athens justice system
that's typically how it's interpreted
yeah I that's that's been an
interpretation for a long time I think
that's pretty
uncontroversial um that the
um the aspects the drives of Revenge
private Revenge have to be brought into
a social context or they're gonna mess
things up for everybody because I mean
here's the thing when we're looking at
these great heroic figures we're looking
at the elites right and
anger is bad within a a regular ordinary
people household right it can lead to to
families breaking apart to bad things
being done to all sorts of problems and
it can be intergenerational right these
these terrible beefs can be set
up when it's a ruling
family it affects the whole city it
affects the entire
community and it creates the potential
for Bloodshed not just to be between
individuals within a family but within
the larger society so it's really
important um that the these matters are
worked out in in these sorts of um
venues right when we have for example
you know in in The Iliad we have um the
two different camps the Trojans and the
the Greeks and they're fighting against
each other and it's perfectly fine for
them to be angry at each other and you
know motivated by thumos it's not good
when uh Achilles and a Agamemnon can't
get along because they're both being
kind of jerks Agamemnon more than
Achilles right and that that you know
causes a lot of death and hardship on on
the side of the Greeks um but it's still
within a war situation when you're
coming home to a city a political
Community where people live and have
their
identity that anger can spill out and
that cycle of Revenge can spill out and
cause all sorts of issues um not just
the things that the furies threaten
disease you know um poison right but an
ongoing taking sides it can lead to
Civil War to a breakdown of society so
those are some really problematic
issues all right any other questions
comments um just a little reminder next
time in January we're going to be
looking at uh
Ides uh Meda and at saicle Ajax so two
other great uh Greek tragedies having to
do with um figures that represent anger
one a uh powerful man Ajax one of the
great Greek Heroes who hates uh ad
deus's guts right and who kills himself
um because of what his his anger leads
to uh and then Meda who is a powerful
sorceress from cus who supports the
douchiest of Greek Heroes Jason in his
Endeavors and then gets betrayed by him
and inflicts a horrible horrible revenge
and knows that she's doing the wrong
thing as she's doing it so she gets
looked at by philosophical figures as
like this is what anger can can lead to
um but we see similar things here you
know um C manestra wouldn't have done
Agamemnon in if he hadn't killed their
daughter
um the furies themselves are are an
embodiment of anger so all right I don't
see any other questions or comments so I
will um bring this to a close and thank
everybody for their their participation
their comments their questions uh we'll
hopefully be doing these monthly from
now now on now that we're getting some
momentum started again and I will see
all of you down the line some of the
other events or perhaps some of the
other online events that we've got going
on this month so have a great day a
great um afternoon